in a recent video i talked about how
many japanese learners have the tendency
to say all verbs in japanese with
accents to be specific i said that many
learners say these verbs to carry
and to play
like hakobu and
which is wrong and sounds quite foreign
again these verbs are more or less flat
as in
now some people saw this video and asked
a great question they said okay how do i
know which verbs in japanese have
accents and which are flat for example
if i learn the verbs to open or to take
a shower using a textbook or an app how
do i know if these verbs have an accent
or if they're flat and if they do have
an accent how do i know where the accent
occurs well we could just try and rely
on our ears and listen for these words
in native speech but this actually
doesn't work very well unless we've
already trained our ears to pick up on
pitch accent and what i mean by this is
that despite the fact that most learners
encounter they learn these words very
early on during their japanese studies
again to open into shower unless they've
studied pitch oxen if they're just
relying on their ears they'll typically
mispronounce them as akeru and abiru
which are both wrong this verb to close
does have an accent and many people hear
this and just kind of assume that its
counterpart to open also has an accent
again as in
but this is incorrect it's akeru
and then this verb to shower is also
accentless as in abiru it's not
but
akeru
and i personally said both of these
verbs to open into shower as well as
many other everyday japanese verbs with
these incorrect patch accent patterns
with these accented pitch accent
patterns because it turns out that again
it's not just as simple as repeat what
you hear because naturally even if you
do your best to repeat something you're
typically still unconsciously playing by
the rules of your native language rather
than the rules of japanese so if we
can't trust our ears at least not until
we've trained them to pick up on pitch
accent then what do we do do we use a
japanese dictionary or some kind of
application to look up the pitch accent
pattern for every verb for every word
for that matter in japanese well we
could but it's much more effective it's
much more practical to instead remember
a handful of important rules that tell
us the pitch acts and patterns for
multiple words or families of words and
one of these rules is the
verb rule and it's very useful this rule
says that all verbs that end with s
always have an accent and that this
accent
always occurs on the second to last beat
of the word for example
utsu to hit
katsu to win
matsu to wait
to hold tatsu to stand
tatsu to pass or to go by as well as
sodatsu to grow up
to stand out
to preserve or maintain
hanatsa to emit or radiate
yakudatsu to be useful etc etc
all of these all verbs in japanese that
end with so they all have an accent and
this accent again always occurs on the
second to last beat of the word now you
may be thinking to yourself well that's
not that difficult i would have said
those verbs that way anyway even if no
one had ever explicitly taught me that
rule but it's very important to remember
that that's probably because
all of these verbs
have accents and that if you just sort
of rely on untrained pronunciation
instincts there's a high probability
you'll end up doing what i did and say
unaccented verbs such as to open
and to shower
as we saw earlier as well as other
everyday japanese verbs like
to wash
to touch
to stop
to quit
to use
to dance etc etc
with the wrong pronunciation patterns
all of the aforementioned verbs again
to open
to shower
to wash
to stop
to quite
to touch
to dance it's called to use etc etc the
list goes on and on all of these are
actually accentless and when you say
these with accents when you unknowingly
say these with accents you're actually
unknowingly making a fairly big
pronunciation mistake now don't get me
wrong people will understand what you're
saying perfectly but it's a bit like
saying an english word
with the accent on the wrong syllable
it's a bit like saying tomorrow rather
than saying tomorrow again people will
understand what you're saying but it
doesn't sound natural it sounds off see
the thing about pitch accent is that and
this can be a very difficult pill to
swallow it certainly was for me
once you start studying it you realize
that
you can't it can be a little bit
dangerous to rely on untrained
pronunciation instincts to rely
to just simply trust your ears if you've
never trained your ears and assume that
you're able to perfectly
reproduce whatever you're hearing in
other words once you start studying
pitch accent you're likely to have the
realization of
okay i know that this pronunciation
feels most natural to me and i know that
i've been using it for months or maybe
even years but
is this in fact the correct
pronunciation and this of course is why
a rule like the
rule is super super useful for people
that do want to sound as natural as
possible because it just takes out all
the guesswork we can say okay i know
that i'm still training my ears i'm
still learning this the basics of this
pitch accent thing
but i also know that
all these verbs all the verbs in
japanese that end with
are pronounced this way and that because
of that i don't have to memorize them
one by one it's a big group of words
okay done out of the way memorized that
saves me time and i can use that time to
memorize the trickier verbs the verbs
that can't be memorized with a single
rule so again if you're interested in
sounding as natural as possible then try
and remember that all verbs in japanese
that end with
do have an accent and that that accent
occurs on the second to last beat of the
verb and if you'd like to learn more
rules like this there's actually one
more rule that pairs really well with
this one it essentially doubles the
efficacy how effective this rule is
i've got i explain a bunch of rules like
this in my patreon series linked down
below but then on top of these kind of
rules there's also some exercises and
anki decks that you can use to help
train your ears to pick up on pitch
accent in japanese and kind of finally
fix get over those
native instincts those instincts that
you have from your own native language
so if you think that might be useful for
your particular japanese learning goals
then there's a link in the description
down below okay i hope that this video
was useful and i'll see you guys again
soon
you